la estenosis pylori k es una enfermedad
en la cual una parte del estómago del
bebé está bloqueada o anormalmente
estrecha localizado entre el esófago y
el intestino delgado el estómago
almacena y comienza a digerir la leche
algunas de las partes principales del
estómago son el fondos
el cuerpo
la región pylori acá
que incluye la cavidad y el canal pylori
co
y el píloro
la pared del estómago contiene varias
capas de músculo
al final de la región pylori acá las
capas musculares forman un anillo grueso
llamado esfínter pylori co el esfínter
pylori ccoo rodea una apertura hacia el
intestino delgado llamado píloro
el esfínter pylori ccoo normalmente se
contrae lo suficiente para sostener la
leche en el estómago mientras las
contracciones mezclan y descomponen la
leche
de vez en cuando olas más fuertes de
contracciones estomacales empujan la
leche fuera del estómago a medida que el
músculo pylori co se relaja la leche
pasa a través del píloro hacia el
intestino delgado
por razones desconocidas algunos bebés
desarrollan estenosis pylori acá en la
cual capas musculares anormalmente
gruesas en el esfínter pylori ccoo
bloquean el píloro
las contracciones estomacales no pueden
empujar la leche del estómago del bebé a
través del píloro bloqueado como
resultado la leche en el estómago no
puede pasar así el intestino delgado lo
que provoca que el bebé vomité la leche
forzosamente
el vómito puede provocar deshidratación
severa una condición en la cual el
cuerpo pierde mucha agua
los síntomas comunes de la
deshidratación incluyen ojos hundidos
sin lágrimas cuando el bebé llora un
punto blando hundido en la parte
superior de la cabeza y orinar - obtener
una orina marrón o de color amarillo
oscuro afortunadamente la deshidratación
no es una amenaza inmediata para la vida
después de que la deshidratación es
tratada el bebé requiere una operación
llamada píloro miotomía para abrir el
píloro bloqueado esta operación será
hecha uno o dos meses después del
nacimiento cuando la condición es
descubierta antes de la operación se le
dará anestesia general al bebé para que
duerma durante toda la operación
se le insertará un tubo respiratorio por
la nariz o boca y en la tráquea para
ayudar al bebé a respirar durante la
operación
comúnmente el cirujano hará cinco
incisiones muy pequeñas cerca o en el
ombligo y en los lados derecho o
izquierdo de la parte superior del
abdomen luego se insertarán pequeños
tubos para una cámara e instrumentos
quirúrgicos
a través de estas incisiones el cirujano
ubicará cuidadosamente el esfínter
pylori co grueso
una incisión será hecha a lo largo de la
parte exterior del esfínter pylori ccoo
la incisión sólo pasará a través de la
capa muscular dejando el revestimiento
de tejido interno intacto
el cirujano insertará un instrumento
quirúrgico para ampliar la incisión y
esparcir las fibras musculares
esta incisión llamada una píloro
miotomía suavizará el músculo del
esfínter pylori ccoo de modo que las
contracciones estomacales sean capaces
de empujar la comida a través del píloro
hacia el intestino delgado
finalmente el cirujano cerrará la
incisión de la piel con suturas solubles
o tiras de sutura cutánea
después del procedimiento el niño será
llevado a la sala de recuperación para
ser monitoreado
se le administrara analgésicos
la alimentación comenzará brevemente
después de la operación
se dará de alta al bebé dentro de uno o
dos días una vez que pueda alimentarse
normalmente y mantenerse bien hidratado